You've seen several commands, like LS,
Uptime, and cowsay that do something,
and then immediately return
you to the shell prompt.
But not all programs do that.
Some programs are a little
bit more interactive.
They take over the terminal for
as long as they're running, and
then we get the shell back
when the program exits.
Take, for instance, ping.
Ping let's you test whether another
machine on the internet is alive, and
how long it takes to send a message
to that machine and back.
Let's see you ping 8.8.8.8,
which is Google's public DNS server.
Very fast and well connected, so
we should always be able to get to it.
Ping starts and it prints out a line for
each successful echo, but
it doesn't stop on its own and
give you your shell back.
Instead, you have to tell it to stop.
One of the most common ways to
tell a program like this to stop
is to type Ctrl+C which
sends the interrupt signal.
When you do that, ping stops,
prints out a summary, and
you get your shell prompt back.
But some programs have
a different behavior.
There's a really common design in
Linux programs where a program will
read from what's called standard input,
or stdin and
write to what's called standard output,
or stdout.
This allows programs to be chained
together on to a pipeline which is
a little bit beyond
the scope of this course.
When you run a program like
this from the terminal,
it'll read from your keyboard input and
write back to the terminal screen.
And very often when your input is done
you want to send it an end of file
character which you do by typing Ctrl+D.
Here's an example.
The sort program,
which sorts lines in alphabetical order.
If you run sort and then type or
paste in some text,
it will print those lines out sorted.
But it can't do any sorting until
it's received the last line and
that's what typing Ctrl+D tells it.
You have to use Ctrl+D instead of
Ctrl+C if you want the sorted output.
Ctrl+C will just cause it to exit.
But there we go, there are the four
lines that I typed in, sorted.
Programs like sort are called line
based programs because they read input
one line at a time until they
reach the end of the input.
You can usually use them on files as
well as on text that you type in or
paste into the terminal.
You'll see a few more of
them later in the course.